الطعام الذي لم يتم تحضيره في المنزل أو يتم تسليمه في
صندوق
ولكن الشيف الذي تم تطويره بخبرة والمطبخ
الجميل
عاد بعد أكثر من عام من
الإغلاق والقيود التي
تعج بمطاعم لندن مرة أخرى
من مطعمه الشهير nopi
chef yotam aralenge أخبرنا أن الأمر يتعلق
بجمع الناس معًا
حيث  شخص يقدم الطعام من أجل لقمة
العيش ولا يفعل
ذلك يشعر بشعور رهيب وغير
طبيعي أخبرنا مؤلف 11 كتاب طهي أن
الإغلاق أجبره
على التغيير والابتكار وهذا هو المكان
الذي يحدث فيه كل السحر
وراء الكواليس هناك مرونة هائلة
في صناعة الضيافة  الأشخاص
الذين يعتقدون أن على أقدامهم يتصرفون على
أقدامهم ،
لذا كصناعة انتقلنا
سريعًا من
خدمة الأشخاص في الموقع إلى عمليات التسليم
وتناول الطعام ، قال
رئيس الطهاة ديفيد برافو إنه استغل
وقته في المنزل
للإبداع في الحصول على كل هذا الوقت.
نوع من التفكير في
الوصفات الجديدة للعاصمة الجديدة أو ما يمكننا فعله بشأن التسريبات
أو ما يمكننا فعله بالسيارات التي تستخدم
بأشكال مختلفة
عندما يتوق الناس إلى
تناول الطعام في
النهاية ، لا تستطيع الصناعة العثور على
الموارد البشرية اللازمة لخدمتهم ،
فنحن نكافح من أجل التوظيف على جميع الجبهات ،
لذلك تضع إعلانًا لحمال المطبخ
ولديك عدد قليل جدًا من المرشحين الذين
يقدمون ثلثهم.  أعيد فتح الأماكن
دون عدد
كافٍ من الموظفين وفقًا لإحدى
الاستطلاعات لقواعد الهجرة بعد خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد
الأوروبي والشعور بعدم الاستقرار
يجعل التوظيف والاحتفاظ بهم أكثر
صعوبة
أخبرنا المدير العام بيير مالوف أن
العديد من أصدقائه وزملائه قد
استقالوا من وظائفهم.
لقد صرخت قليلاً في الحافلة التي ذهبت إلى العمل
لأنني أعتقد أنك
لم تتح لنا الفرصة لنقول وداعًا لقد
كانت كتلة من الهجرة الجماعية لدرجة
أننا لم نحصل على الإغلاق مطلقًا ، وعلينا
الآن إعادة البناء مرة أخرى.
كان نصف
عمال الضيافة من مواطني الاتحاد الأوروبي
ولكن خلال العام الماضي عاد الكثير منهم
إلى أوروبا تظهر البيانات الحكومية
ولكن بينما تكافح الصناعة لإيجاد
حلول ، فإن طلب المستهلكين
يرتفع بشكل كبير  الشيء الذي أنا
واثق منه حقًا هو أن الناس سيرغبون في
تناول الطعام في الخارج لأنها
واحدة من أفراح المجتمع القليلة التي
لا يزال لدينا حتى الآن المطاعم هي
الأماكن المثالية لذلك
الأمل في أن يؤدي إحياء مشهد الطعام في لندن
إلى النهضة
ولم الشمل  سلمى دوزيس CNN
لندن